tell me a little bit about yourself what
do you do for a
living I do lots of things but my core
business is I'm supposed to say is I'm a
wine writer so I'm a yeah I taste wine
for a living you taste wine for a living
this sounds like a fantastic job how
does that how does that work you know do
you taste wines at night how does it
work when do you when does your day
start um start my day usually starts
quite early so um the best time for me
to start is as early as I can so
sometimes it's you know 7 8 in the
morning and I'll get up and quietly sort
of pad out to my desk which is actually
my kitchen table where I'm sitting now
and um and I'll start tasting wines
because wait at 7 in the morning whoa
yeah well because my brain's fresh you
know and my taste buds are fresh there
hasn't been stuff happening to them
during the day I haven't had a zillion
cups of coffee
you know it's like well the only thing
that's not fresh is is yeah my teeth
because you don't clean your teeth
before you start tasting wi right you
can't brush your teeth before you taste
wine because you're just going to be
tasting the Crest toothpaste I'm getting
money for them to men Crest
specifically we don't have Crist over
here what what's great about Crist why
should I be using oh I don't know I just
said that uh but now with extra
whitening powders have you ever
considered brushing your teeth with wine
yeah would you ever brush your teeth
with wine well yes you can brush your
teeth with wine but the outcome won't be
that great so particularly if it's red
wine um after a day of tasting red wine
your teeth can go this really attractive
Bluey purple gray and it it sticks and
everyone wants you to smile and yon you
say that you get up at 7 in the morning
and you start drinking and you drink
throughout the day tasting tasting
conting not drinking it no no no tasting
and tasting and tasting um and then uh
do you actually write about it later on
or are you just an
alcoholic I write about it later on so
the thing is I've got special equipment
my most treasured possession is my spit
bucket
oh which which I carry with me
everywhere it's um it's got its own it's
got its own handle see nice I can take
it around town carrying a bucket that's
nice regurgitated wine yeah how you know
you yeah you don't want to look inside
it it's um it's not not pretty but you
know the thing is you you um you look at
the wine you sniff the wine you swish it
around in your mouth you um think okay
what am I smelling what am I tasting and
you're writing notes the whole time and
then you spit it out so you actually you
must get some alcohol though some
alcohol must get passed through uh
various capillaries in your mouth right
yes yeah a little bit for sure you a I
mean after a long day of just even wine
tasting do you ever get a little tipsy
or yes yeah I mean you can't help but
well not Tipsy but it's like you get
it's exhausting after a big day like if
you're judging in a competition and it's
you know over 100 Wines a day by the end
of it you're you I mean for start you do
not want to drive you don't want to um
operate any heavy machinery or anything
involving a lot of technology and you
probably just want a cup of tea in a in
a beer you know at the end of it and
then some more wine yeah this is
fascinating to me because uh I I just
you know I've always thought that even
the guy who tastes ice cream at the Ice
Cream Factory uh at the end of the day
he must have some days who like oh my
God if I have to have another taste of
ice cream I'll go crazy do you can you
enjoy a glass of wine when you go out to
a restaurant or is that the last thing
you want when it's your
job well if like I said before if it's
been a really big day of tasting if I've
tasted a lot of wine then yeah I'm going
to I want a Negroni or a um you know or
something or a nice cleansing ale or
whatever you know or something pills or
something you know pills something that
gives you a high but it's like a clean
High yeah a clean High yeah a clean high
that can't be smelled on your breath you
know um that's uh that's
fascinating well I guess sometimes you
know if you go out to a restaurant
everyone goes they hand you the wine
list they go oh you choose you choose
what we all drink come on and it's like
sometimes I don't want to do that and
other times you'll have friends that go
oh let's go out for a girl night let's
go have wines and I'm
like yeah it's your profession and
there's no way that you can just chill
and enjoy a glass of wine because all
your friends are going to like the wine
but you're going to be
thinking little bit um too many Citrus
not notes for a
cab right uh I'm tasting I'm tasting
cinnamon when I feel I should be tasting
balt you know uh
right yeah possibly not salt maybe a I
said balt I meant the rock BT oh like a
mineral oh we say yeah yeah balt or
granite or graphite
characters yeah you're good you're good
at this oh I just say things I don't
think that I actually have a good pet
how would we know if I have a good we're
actually prepared to test
we could he could describe you could
tell if he act for this yeah do I have a
pet or not do you think you could tell
yeah yeah because everyone does everyone
has a palette but you know some people
can actually verbalize what they're
smelling and tasting better than others
everyone can taste you know it just
takes practice so um I don't know what
have we got to throw in front of
you or a cracker or some Team Coco snack
cabinet and uh from the the fruity side
of things we've got got Welch's fruit
snacks if that's you know for your fruer
wines MH uh for your more autumnal we've
got bare baked crunchy Fuji and reds
apple chips and then finally if we want
to go something just a little bit more
Baseline we've got Barnum's Animal
Crackers con what what do you guys think
is best well I'm going to defer to the
expert yavon yavon what do you think I
should be tasting oh my goodness so hold
the options up again for me to have a
look it animal crackers apple chips
fruit
snacks I think apple chips let's go the
apple chips okay all right which one do
you want I don't understand why if I
know what it is ahead of time doesn't
that cheating I'm just going to say it
tastes like apple it's got a kind of a
CH no no no I want I want you to tell me
what kind of apple and yeah because you
have different Apple varieties right
yeah but I don't know I don't know about
Apple varieties I don't get out much
okay is it you think it smells like a
red apple or a green apple all right
right now I'm
smelling I'm getting Red Apple I think
it's it's a red apple it's also on the
package yeah it says Fuji Fuji and red
well I didn't see that actually there a
red apple and you're really good
at I didn't see that I honestly didn't
see that but I feel like you could make
it up all right well deconstruct way I'm
trying to do something you know oh
you're you're taking this all right so
I'm looking just at you I'm not looking
at the package but I did I did sense it
was a red apple should I taste it yes
taste it and think about does it taste
really sweet or is it dry or is it
creamy or is it does it have a crunchy
texture or does it have a
rubbery a Tang has a kind of a Tang a
sharpness to it okay um would you say
it's refreshing
or I would I would say it's no it's not
refreshing um it's because I know my
brain is saying oh it's an apple but
then it's all dry and crunchy so my
brain is saying Red Alert Red Alert this
is a dried dried up old Apple that you
found it's from the Civil War war or
something and then that's what you write
that's what you write down I would say
this is this is an upsetting
wine um makes me think of a desiccated
old fruit um yeah I um I I think this is
a terrible way to test my ability to to
check out wine I think that Matt gave no
thought to this he just went to the
snack cabinet grab some I did pick
out the three things that I wanted to
eat at that moment I know now we're now
we're snacking it's um so here's the
thing
think citrusy yeah okay that's cool but
Apple's not a citrus it's a tree fruit
I I'm telling you that it has a citrusy
Tang to it so I do think that it has I
give my own thank you for handing me the
one You' been well here's a trick though
Conan here's something you can do and
this is what I do when I'm tasting wine
like I've got one right here this is sh
oh good I have a wine right here oh oh
good turning to be a good day yeah uh
yeah cool because we've got a big
chardonay Symposium happening in my town
at the moment so there's just chardonay
everywhere but what I do when I'm
tasting wine is I sometimes think if
this wine was a person what kind of
person would it be so I kind of think
about the wine with personality traits
as well as Aromas and flavors this is
turning more into a test of can I open a
bottle of wine let alone oh wait it's
got a cork yeah it's got a see corks
very often why all screw tops now well a
lot of the win is under screw top
because screw tops are amazing for wine
they are the greatest things
ever in my opinion okay I've poured
myself just a little bit great okay now
your glass actually your glass is quite
good I like the shape because the shape
is really important when assessing wine
because you don't want one of those
small Stumpy short little glasses this
is ating the wine one this is ating the
wine right now I'm swirling the wine
around as I've seen people do in movies
yes but also you could go cir toay on it
and um hold it from the foot and swirl
see very good hold it from the foot
you're holding it you're holding it from
the stem can I say one thing this class
is really dirty yeah dis spots all over
these I mean you know what the problem
is we have a podcast studio and uh Aaron
Blart who works for us uh is a is a
bachelor and I think he's uh I think he
lives he's a hoarder and he's not that
good with the um no I think he wouldn't
know a clean glass if it was
shoved where the sun don't shine so no
anyway it doesn't matter I'm sure some
detrus is getting in there what do you
think you know how you're doing very
well but but host I mean the way you're
holding it is giving me anxiety so see
how I'm holding the foot of the can you
really do this in public without getting
beaten up yeah yeah and then you can do
it like like lots of lots of sing it put
a wrist put a bit of wrist in crushing
it oh you guys got it too I don't's a
professional Drinker son's
drinking you're doing exceptionally well
my darling right okay so now going to be
my new job was drinking in the womb oh
come on no you were I had a nice wine
glass in the womb okay so I've swirled
this about as much as I can swirl it
yeah you swirled it loads so enough of
the swirling now we're going to sniff it
and we're not going to do any of this
um stuff you know like it you
just get your nose right in there you
see people you just get your nose right
in
there are we are we trying the same kind
of wine right now yeah oh we are as her
no oh well what a great
experiment someone in New Zealand with a
glass of wine and someone uh in uh Los
Angeles with some cookies and see if
they have the same put them on zoom and
see if they have the same notes this is
called Boon's Farm Strawberry Hill what
is it really it's called rurn Russian
River Valley Chardon 2020 okay okay
great great great so it is a charday
brilliant all right all right and you
have a charday all right let me tell you
what I'm getting a chard I I have the um
the Tony Bish nice label HK Bay
chardonay this
is is that called Bish Bish Bish oh I'm
sorry I went a different way what can
you see that yeah yeah so Tony Bish now
he is the absolute Guru he's like the
gandal of charday making here in New
Zealand he is Mr charday all he does he
just makes chaday the whole time so this
is his Heartwood and it's beautiful like
anyway enough I love him so we're going
to smell it and we want to we want to
smell interesting things so I'm like in
my New Zealand Chardonnay M I'm getting
Aromas of toasty Oak like um Rising
dough biscuits and uh roast peaches
smell Shard toasty toasted stone fruit
and like um
toasted stone fruit and spice you know
just a little bit of spice I'm getting
hints I'm I'm getting hints of
microphone oh no oh wait my microphone
is closer to my nose than the wine hold
on a second well that'll do
it I
I I'm
getting
Essence
uhhuh well it's a it's a waiting yeah I
don't know I don't have good words use
your words
does it smell does it smell fruity does
it smell fruity okay it smells fruity
but it also smells smell like I'm
getting kind of a grapefruit oh okay
good that's great and uh I'm also
getting what if he's wrong though
because I'm reading the label no okay
he's not wrong because grapefruit is in
sh it's a that you definitely get
grapefruity characters in good
Chardonnay so well done thank you yeah
and you know it is have a little bit of
a mineral it doesn't uh I'm going to say
it it it's feels a little uh drier than
a normal Chardonnay uh just taste it
let's taste it well I think son already
did I swallowed it is it okay to
swallow we can SW you can swallow it's
all right you don't need the bucket oh
oh come on easy what are you guys
getting up to down
there what let he you do it you haven't
had anyone spit on microphone before or
on I'm not judging you I'm getting this
is very nice say for for podcast wine
this is pretty good this cool marine
influenced region is perfectly suited to
exceptionally flavored Chardonnay fresh
layers of green apple and pear are
accented by a creamy richness due to
sirly
aging okay okay so do you know what
sirly aging means and this is a tip for
anyone that's listening watching see
that on a label someone goes sirly it
doesn't mean you know Moody and angry
which is what
Surly l y means sirly means on leaves so
the leaves uh when the yeast is finished
doing its ferment and it's um it's
basically dyed they drop to the bottom
of the barrel or the tank and they form
like a really attractive gray green
paste in the bottom of the of the vessel
and some wine makers will leave the wine
on that on the leaves for an extended
period of time or they'll stir the
leaves through the wine which gives a
kind of a creamy textural character to
the wine so if you see sir Lee on the
back label of a wine bottle or on a
tasty note you can go ah right so it's
been aged on its leaves and everyone
will think you're a guru okay so that's
yeah but that's great that's a really
great descriptor um it's really good and
the mineral thing is interesting Conan
because when you have grapes by by the
seaside you're going to get that saline
character in the soils you're going to
get seab bre on the you know on the
leaves of the vines and that's all going
to end up in the berries and in the
berries ends up in the wine so you did
really well that's great this isn't my
podcast anymore this is not con Brian
needs a fan this is now here's another
thing this is wine talk she please be
quiet she's trying to host our host is
yvon and uh take it yon we're pairing it
with animal crackers is that perfect
okay yeah pair it with anything but one
thing I want you to think about guys so
Sona this could be for you one thing
that that I think about when I'm trying
to figure out is this a great wine like
is it a really good value wine is it
deliciously made think about the length
of flavor so have a sip swallow it and
then just kind of
count how long you can still taste that
wine for because you know so many wines
you know you pour it in the glass and it
looks pretty and you sniff it you go M
that smells delicious and you taste it
you yeah that's really nice and then it
just disappears and you're like well I'm
going to have to keep sipping to keep
the thrill alive yeah and before you
know it you know you're you're wrapped
around the clothes line outside going I
think we all know what it's like to
chase that thrill when you chase that
thrilled on a bottle the bottle always
wins the bottle always wins win
y